baby seems to view an author of The
Great Gatsby at ages II study guide to
surviving truck world joy behar
[Applause]
[Music]
yes so great to see your never grow old
you always it the same old are you
afraid to die oh it was but now it's
more likely but III want everyone just
cuz I love you and I you always make me
laugh but also because I feel like I'm
also having an argument like almost on a
weekly basis with other Democrats where
you were on my side
yeah I keep saying Democrats are too
nice they don't and you are my oh I
write they don't go for the jugular you
don't go for that when they go low we go
high they go we should go exactly crazy
don't you understand they're crazy you
don't deal with white supremacist I'm
not talking I'm talking to you but but
yes I mean I what happened to that gene
in the Democrat makeup I mean it wasn't
that way with Bobby Kennedy and Ted
Banda and John F Kennedy they were tough
they weren't this this kind of two nice
Democrat but busy get laid well
[Laughter]
certainly part of it I think the problem
is political correctness yes believe I
did a show about that some years ago
when John Kerry was running I saw him at
something and I said you gotta deal with
these people you need to be tough what
are you gonna do to deal with these
Republicans he was like don't worry I
can handle it no he didn't he didn't
they don't they don't know somewhere
that gene is it went recessive okay so
you have to speak very simply to people
they don't want to hear all this wonky
stuff that you hear on CNN and MSNBC
go right for the jugular the way Trump
does it he's smart in that way he is
it's the only thing that's smart about
exactly he's he's
terrific conman yeah but I mean you play
club not club I know not Claude I mean
clubs like what do you consider theaters
yes and it's a little the atmosphere is
a little more constrained than it uses
well you can't say anything now I mean
well you can we can because we're a
little grandfathered in again with the
old age I don't like to work anymore as
a stand-up partly because anything you
say they write it down they tape you yes
they wrap her tweet about it yes and the
like James Corden got in trouble last
week whatever Rose McGowan it's like a
layoff the comedians okay leave that can
be we like the philosophers of the toy
not Socrates and Aristotle but we are
the philosophers right now is that
because we can work in the clubs we
don't care about these jobs like this
job on my job we can always work so we
will say whatever we want
well speak for yourself what they go
back to that blog but all right so let's
talk about men and their and their bad
behavior because this is this like I
said this is a watershed time this is
things will never be the same
why do you think now I mean was a year
ago when this when the Trump tape came
out why not five years ago were 10 years
ago why not at the dawn of the women's
liberation movement why is it now that
finally I mean it's a it's kind of
amazing I don't think that I'm not too
optimistic because really Anita Hill
came out and then we had we have
Clarence stop but it's a difficult come
on it's a different era with social
media and all the women joining in and
all the all these but there's still most
mentoring of the people in power
what dude they're the ones in power
they're the ones who intimidate the
women and they're the ones who say
you're not gonna get the job unless you
let me look and let's unless you look at
my penis
basically that's what they said I know
when you read about this you know they
all have it they all I don't know they
all have an M oh yeah it's just like
like Cosby like here take some drugs
right lock you out or or you know like
masturbating
we're just rubbing an erection yeah I I
thought I didn't know women all my life
I don't know man what did Bill O'Reilly
do that that got that woman thirty two
million dollars what what could you
possible do i I wouldn't [ __ ] him for
thirty two million dollars
I don't know why do you get so that
girls I know he's not worth 32 million
right and I must say it when you look at
the list of people it is always married
guys it's always married you just saying
why is that because they have shitty sex
lives oh yeah I think you might think
they're not having a sect of
satisfactory board at home no no that's
nothing to do with my Alperin is accused
of masturbating under the desk while
he's talking to somebody was that got to
do with him being married let's bring
the wives into it business while these
jerks are jerking off my book your book
[Applause]
Donald Trump
the book is called The Great Gatsby
what's it called what's it about I
thought I told with other top titles
what do you think of the war and
hairpiece
that was one moby dick head
what other titles did you think when I
wrote it for Trump's Trump anti-trump
errs have you if you're a trump
supporter don't buy the book
I forbid you to buy the book there's the
book for
[Applause]